Quand vous songez à la résilience et à la technologie, c'est en fait beaucoup plus simple.
Vous allez entendre d'autres intervenants aujourd'hui
qui vont vous parler de choses assommantes,
mais pas en ce qui concerne la technologie.
Il est vraiment facile, en comparaison, d'être résilient
Regardons ce qu'il s'est passé avec Internet,
ces cinq dernières années incroyables,
il est difficile de trouver la bonne analogie.
Nombre de décisions, de réactions potentielles,
de nos attentes du futur,
dépendent de comment on compile les choses
et comment on les catégorise.
Il est tentant de comparer l'éclatement de la bulle Internet
que nous venons de vivre avec la ruée vers l'or
Il est facile de considérer que cette analogie est très différente
des autres que vous auriez pu choisir.
Premièrement, les deux sont réels.
En 1849, pendant cette ruée vers l'or, on a pris plus de 700 millions de dollars
d'or en Californie. C'était on ne peut plus réel.
Internet était aussi très réel. C'est un véritable moyen pour les gens de
communiquer les uns avec les autres. C'est très important.
Enorme bulle! Enorme bulle. Enorme explosion. Enorme explosion.
Si on continue dans ce sens, ces deux choses tiennent beaucoup d'un effet de mode.
Je n'ai pas besoin de vous rappeler tout le battage
autour d'Internet. Comme GetRich.com
Mais vous aviez la même chose autour de la ruée vers l'or. "De l'or, de l'or, de l'or."
soixante-huit hommes riches sur le bateau Portland. Des piles de métal dorés.
Quelques uns avaient cinq mille dollars. Beaucoup avaient encore plus.
Un plus petit nombre rapporta chacun 100 000 $
Les gens étaient très excités lorsqu'ils lisaient ces articles.
L'Eldorado des Etats-Unis d'Amérique.
La découverte de mines d'or inépuisables en Californie.
Le parallèle entre la ruée vers l'or et la ruée vers Internet est très fort.
Ainsi, de nombreuses personnes quittèrent leur activité.
Et ce qui s'était passé - la ruée vers l'or a duré plusieurs années
les gens sur la côte Est en 1849, quand ils ont commencé à recevoir les nouvelles,
pensèrent: " Ah, ce n'est pas possible."
Mais ils continuèrent d'entendre que des gens devenaient riches
et en 1850 ils l'entendaient encore. Et il pensaient que cela n'était pas réel.
A peu près autour de 1852, ils pensaient: "Est ce que je suis stupide
de ne pas me précipiter en Californie?" Et ils commencèrent à penser qu'ils l'étaient.
Ce sont des affaires de communauté par ailleurs.
Les communautés locales de la côte Est se rassemblaient et des équipes complètes
de 10 ou 20 personnes traversèrent les Etats-Unis,
et ils formèrent des compagnies.
Ce n'était typiquement pas des efforts individuels. Mais peu importe
qu'ils fussent avocats ou banquiers, les gens quittèrent leur activité,
peu importe leurs savoir-faire, pour aller orpailler l'or.
Ce type sur la gauche, le Dr Richard Berverley Cole,
vivait à Philadelphie et il prit la voie par le Panama.
Ils prenaient un bateau jusqu'au Panama, un autre à travers l'isthme,
et ils prenaient ensuite un autre bateau pour aller vers le Nord
Ce type, le Dr Toland, est venu en chariot jusqu'en Californie
Cela crée des parallèles aussi. Les docteurs quittaient leurs cabinets.
Ces deux-là ont réussi. Un médecin dans un cas;
un chirurgien dans l'autre.
La même chose est arrivée sur Internet. Vous avez DrKoop.com
(Rires)
Pendant la ruée vers l'or, les gens sautaient littéralement du navire.
Le port de San Francisco était encombré par 600 navires en période de pointe
parce que les navires y arrivaient et les équipages les abandonnaient
pour chercher l'or.
Ainsi il y avait littéralement 600 capitaines et 600 navires.
Ils transformaient les navires en hôtels parce qu'ils ne pouvaient naviguer nulle part.
Il y a eu la fièvre Internet. Et il y a eu la fièvre de l'or.
Et vous avez constaté certains des excès
créés par la fièvre Internet et la même chose est arrivée.
Le fort de San Francisco à cette époque avait à peu près 1 300 soldats.
La moitié déserta pour aller chercher de l'or.
Et on n'aurait pas laisser l'autre moitié partir rechercher la première moitié
de peur qu'ils ne reviennent pas.
(Rires)
Et un des soldats écrivit chez lui, voici ce qu'il dit :
"Le choix entre le bien à 6$ par mois
et le mal à 75$ par jour est plutôt difficile."
Il y a eu un très grand taux de perte pendant la ruée vers l'or. Un très grand taux de perte.
Cela vient de la ruée du Klondike. C'est le passage du col White.
Ils chargèrent leurs mules et leurs chevaux
Et ils n'ont pas planifié correctement.
Ils ne savaient pas la distance qu'ils devaient parcourir,
et ils ont surchargé leurs chevaux avec des centaines de kilos de matériel.
En fait, c'était si dur que la plupart des chevaux moururent
avant de pouvoir atteindre leur point d'arrivée.
On l'a renommé la piste du Cheval Mort.
Le Ministre de l'Intérieur canadien écrivit à cette époque :
"Des milliers de chevaux de bât reposent morts tout au long du chemin
parfois en groupe sous les falaises,
avec des bât et des sacs là d'où ils étaient tombés,
parfois en masses enchevêtrées, remplissant les fondrières
et fournissant les uniques prises d'équilibre pour nos pauvre animaux de charge en route,
qui, je regrette de le dire, étaient souvent épuisés mais encore en vie,
un fait dont nous n'étions pas conscients jusqu'à ce que de misérables carcasses
se retrouvent sous les sabots de notre cavalcade.
Les orbites vides des animaux de bât partout
expliquant les myriades de corbeaux le long de la route.
L'inhumanité dont cette piste a été témoin,
le crève-cœur et la douleur que tant ont endurés
ne peuvent être imaginés. Ils ne peuvent certainement pas être décrits.
Et vous savez, sans l'odeur qui l'accompagnait,
nous avons eu la même chose sur Internet : des très mauvaises évaluations des rythmes de dépenses.
Je vais juste vous en montrer une et vous allez vous en souvenir.
C'est une publicité qui a été diffusée pendant le Super Bowl de l'année 2000.
(Vidéo): Mariée n°1: Vous disiez que vous aviez une grande sélection d'invitations.L'employé: mais certainement.
Marié n°2: Mais alors pourquoi a-t-elle mon invitation ?
Voix off: Ce qui peut une petite chose pour certains... Marié n°3: Tu es a moi, petit homme.
voix off: peut être très important pour vous. Le mari n°1: Est ce que c'est votre femme?
Mari n°2: Non pas pour les prochaines 15 minutes. Voix off: après tout, c'est un jour spécial.
OurBeginning.com. La vie est un évènement, dites-le au monde.
Jeff Bezos : C'est très difficile de comprendre le but de cette publicité.
(Rires)
Mais ils ont dépensé 3,5 millions de dollars
pour diffuser cette pub lors du Super Bowl 2000.
Même si, à l'époque, ils n'avaient qu'un million de dollars de chiffre d'affaires annuels.
Maintenant, c'est là que l'analogie avec la ruée vers l'or diverge,
et je pense assez sérieusement.
C'est que, pendant la ruée vers l'or, quand c'est fini, c'est fini.
Cet homme dit: "Il y a de nombreux hommes à Dawson
en ce moment qui sont vraiment déçus,
Ils ont parcouru des milliers de miles dans un périple dangereux, ils ont risqué leur vie, leur santé et leur propriété,
passé des mois à un travail des plus laborieux
et finalement, leur attentes poussées au plus haut point,
ont atteint le but convoité pour découvrir
qu'il n'y avait rien pour eux là-bas."
Et c'était, bien sûr, le lot commun.
Parce que lorsque vous prenez ce dernier morceau d'or -
et ils l'ont fait incroyablement vite. Je pense que si vous regardez la ruée vers l'or de 1849
Dans toute la région des rivières américaine, en deux ans,
chaque pierre a été retournée. Et après cela, seules les grandes entreprises
qui utilisaient des technologies minières plus sophistiquées
ont commencé à sortir de l'or de là.
Maintenant, il y a une meilleur analogie qui vous permet d'être beaucoup plus optimiste
et cette analogie c'est l'industrie électrique
Il y a de nombreuses similarités entre Internet et l'industrie électrique.
Avec l'industrie électrique, en fait, vous devez -
une d'elles est qu'elles sont toutes deux une sorte de couche d'activité étroite
et horizontale, transversale à de nombreuses industries.
Ce n'est pas une spécificité.
Mais l'électricité c'est aussi très, très vaste, alors vous devez, en quelque sorte, la réduire
Vous savez, cela peut être utilisé comme un incroyable moyen de transmettre l'énergie
C'est un incroyable moyen de coordination,
c'est un vecteur très fin, des flots d'informations.
Il y a un tas de choses intéressantes au sujet de l'électricité
Et le coté révolutionnaire de l'électricité sur lequel je veux me concentrer
c'est l'âge d'or de l'électroménager.
l'application révolutionnaire qui a préparé le monde à l'électroménager c'était l'ampoule électrique.
Ainsi l'ampoule électrique a permis le câblage du monde.
Personne ne pensaient aux équipements électroménagers lorsque l'on câblait le monde.
Ils pensaient réellement que
ils n'apportaient pas l'électricité dans les foyers.
Ils apportaient la lumière dans les maisons.
Mais vraiment, il y a eu l'électricité. Cela a pris du temps.
C'était énorme et comme vous pouvez vous y attendre, fondé sur d'énormes capitaux
Toutes les rues devaient être éventrées.
Ce travail était en cours jusque dans le bas Manhattan
là où ils construisirent quelques une des premières stations électriques.
Et ils éventraient toutes les rues.
La compagnie Edison Electric, qui devient Edison General Electric,
qui devint General Electric,
paya pour toutes ces excavations dans les rues. C'était incroyablement cher.
Mais ce n'est pas - et ce n'est pas le coté qui est vraiment le plus semblable au Web.
Parce que, souvenez vous, le Web doit se situer
au sommet de cette infrastructure lourde
qui a été mise en place pour les réseaux téléphonique de longues distances.
Ainsi, tout le cablage et toute l'infrastructure lourde --
Je reviens maintenant, en quelque sorte, à la partie explosive du Web en 1994,
quand cela croissait de 2300% par an.
Comment cela pouvait s'accroître de 2300% par an en 1994
alors que les gens n'investissaient pas vraiment dans le Web ?
Eh bien, c'est parce que cette infrastructure lourde avait déjà été installée.
De la même facon, l'ampoule a permis la mise en place de la lourde infrastructure
puis l'électroménager commença à apparaitre.
Et c'était énorme. Le premier appareil fut le ventilateur électrique --
c'était le ventilateur électrique 1890.
Et les appareils électriques, l'âge d'or de l'électroménager a vraiment duré.
Cela depend de la manière dont vous voulez le mesurer--
mais cela se situe entre 40 ans et 60 ans. Cela remonte à longtemps.
Cela commence environ vers 1890. Le ventilateur électrique a été un très grand succès.
Le fer à repasser, aussi a été un très grand succès.
D'ailleurs, c'est le début des procès contre l'amiante.
Rires...
Il y a de l'amiante sous cette poignée là.
C'est le premier aspirateur, l'aspirateur Skinner 1905.
de l'entreprise Hoover. Et celui ci pesait 92 livres.
il fallait deux personnes pour l'utiliser et il coûtait le quart du prix d'une voiture.
Par conséquent, ca n'a pas été un succès commercial.
C'était véritablement un produit d'early-adopter--
Rires.
cet aspirateur Skinner 1905.
Mais trois ans plus tard, autour de 1908, il pesait 40 livres,
Bon, tous ces trucs ne rencontraient pas de grands succès.
Rires
C'est la presse électrique à cravate, qui n'a jamais vraiment marché.
Les gens, j'imagine, ont décidé qu'ils ne froisseraient pas leurs cravates.
Ceux là non plus ne sont jamais véritablement devenu populaires:
le chauffeur et sécheur électrique de chaussure. Cela n'a jamais fait de grosses ventes.
Il se faisait en, disons, six couleurs différentes.
(Rires)
Je ne sais pas pourquoi. Mais je pense, vous savez,
que parfois ce n'est tout simplement pas le moment pour une invention.
peut être faut il donner une autre chance à celle-ci.
Aussi, je pensais que nous pourrions faire une pub Super Bowl pour celui-ci.
On aurait besoin du bon partenaire. Et je pensais que vraiment --
(Rires)
Je pensais que cela pourrait vraiment marcher de lui donner une nouvelle chance.
Alors, le grille pain a été un succés
parce que les gens avaient l'habitude de faire des toasts sur le feux,
cela prennait pas mal de temps et d'attention.
Je voudrais faire remarquer une chose. C'est -- vous les mecs vous savez ce que c'est.
Ils n'avaient pas encore inventé la prise électrique.
C'était ainsi -- souvenez vous, ils n'avaient pas câblé les maison pour l'électricité.
Ils câblaient pour la lumière. Ainsi votre - vos appareils pouvaient se brancher.
Ils devaient - généralement, chaque pièce avait une ampoule au plafond.
Et vous le branchiez là-haut.
En fait, si vous avez vu le carrousel du progrès à Disney World,
Vous l'avez déjà vu. Voici les fils qui arrivent dans cette fixation pour ampoule.
Tous les appareils se branchaient là. Et vous aviez juste à dévisser votre ampoule
si vous vouliez brancher un appareil.
L'autre chose qui a vraiment beaucoup compté, c'était la machine à laver.
Bon, c'était un objet de jalousie et de convoitise.
Tout le monde voulait une de ces machines à laver électriques.
Sur le coté gauche, c'était l'eau savonneuse.
Et il y a un rotor ici -- que ce moteur fait tourner.
Et cela lavait vos vêtements.
Là, c'est l'eau propre de rinçage. Et vous retiriez les vêtements,
les mettiez ici, et vous passiez les vêtements à travers ce lamineur électrique.
C'était un truc énorme !
Vous le mettiez sur la véranda. C'était un peu compliqué et un peu pénible.
Et vous tiriez un long câble jusque dans la maison
où vous pouviez le visser dans la prise de l'ampoule.
(Rires)
Et c'est en fait un point important de ma présentation,
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas inventé l'interrupteur.
C'est venu bien plus tard- l'interrupteur sur les appareils électriques --
parce que cela n'avait aucun sens.
Je veux dire, vous ne vouliez pas que ce truc encombre la prise de l'ampoule.
Alors, quand vous aviez fini avec ça, vous le dévissiez.
C'est ce qu'ils faisaient. Ils ne l'éteignaient pas.
Comme je l'ai dit avant, on n'avait pas encore inventé la prise électrique,
et la machine à laver était un appareil particulièrement dangereux.
Et là --
quand vous faites des recherches là dessus, il y a des descriptions macabre
de gens qui se sont fait prendre leurs cheveux et leurs vêtements dans ces appareils.
Et ils ne pouvaient même pas couper le courant
parce que le câble était vissé dans la prise de l'ampoule dans la maison.
(Rires)
Et il n'y avait pas d'interrupteur, alors c'était pas trop bien.
Et alors là, vous pensez que c'était incroyablement stupide de la part de nos aïeux
de brancher des choses dans la prise de l'ampoule de cette manière.
Mais, vous savez, avant que j'aille plus loin dans la condamnation de nos aïeux,
Je pense que je devrais vous montrer ça : c'est ma salle de réunion.
C'est un complet bricolage, si vous me demandez.
Tout d'abord, c'est installé n'importe comment. Cette ampoule --
(Rires)
et le fil ne cessait pas de s'arracher alors je l'ai scotché.
C'est supposé -- ne me lancez pas. Mais c'est pas le pire.
Voilà à quoi ça ressemble sous mon bureau.
J'ai pris cette photo il y a deux jours seulement.
Eh bien, nous n'avons pas beaucoup progressé depuis 1908.
(Rires)
C'est un bazar complet !
Et vous savez, on pense que ça va mieux,
mais avez vous essayé d'installer le wifi vous même ?
(Rires)
Je vous mets au défi d'essayer. C'est très dur.
Je connais des docteurs en informatique --
Ca les a fait fondre en larmes.
Et tout ça dans l'hypothèse où vous avez déjà l'Adsl chez vous.
Essayez d'installer l'Adsl chez vous.
Les techniciens qui le font tous les jours, n'y arrivent même pas.
Ils doivent -- disons, venir trois fois.
Un de mes amis me racontait une histoire.
Non seulement ils se sont déplacés et ont dû attendre,
mais les techniciens, quand ils sont finalement arrivés,
pour la troisième fois, ils ont dû appeler quelqu'un.
Ils étaient réellement content que le type ait un haut parleur sur son téléphone
parce que là, ils ont dû rester en ligne une heure
pour parler à quelqu'un qui leur donne un code d'accès
après cela.
Alors, ne sommes pas nous mêmes un peu bricolos ?
Au passage, l'Adsl c'est de la bidouille.
Je veux dire que c'est une paire de fils de cuivres torsadés qui n'a jamais été conçu
dans ce but.
Vous connaissez toute l'affaire.
Nous sommes très très primitifs. Voilà de quoi il s'agit.
parce que ,en fait, la résilience -- si vous pensez en termes de ruée vers l'or,
alors vous seriez plutôt déprimés à l'instant.
parce que la dernière pépite d'or est partie.
Mais ce qui est bien avec l'innovation c'est qu'il n'y a pas de dernière pépite.
Toute nouveauté crée deux nouvelles questions et deux nouvelles opportunités.
Et si vous croyez en cela, alors vous croyez que là où nous sommes --
c'est ce que je pense: je crois que là où nous en sommes c'est un incroyable bazar -
et je n'ai même pas parlé des interfaces utilisateurs sur le Web.
Mais il y a tellement de bidouille, tellement de trucs sensationnels,
nous en sommes au stade de la machine à laver Hurley de 1908 avec Internet.
C'est là où nous en sommes. Nous ne nous faisons pas prendre nos cheveux dedans,
mais c'est le niveau primitif où nous sommes.
Nous sommes en 1908
Et si vous croyez cela, alors des trucs comme ça ne vous dérangent pas. C'est en 1996:
"Tous les aspects négatifs s'accumulent pour en faire une expérience en ligne qui ne vaut pas la peine."
1998: "Amazon.toast." En 1999: "Amazon.bomb."
Ma mère déteste cette image.
(Rires)
Mais vous savez, si vous pensez vraiment que c'est le tout,
tout début, si vous pensez que c'est la machine à laver Hurley 1908,
alors vous êtes incroyablement optimistes. Et je pense que nous en sommes là.
Et je pense qu'il y a encore plus d'innovation devant nous.
qu'il y en a derrière nous.
En 1917, Sears -- Je ne voudrais pas me tromper.
C'est la publicité qu'ils ont lancé en 1917.
Il est dit: " utilisez votre électricité pour plus que de la lumière."
Et je pense que c'est là où nous en sommes
Nous sommes en avance, très en avance. Merci beaucoup.